Speaker 1: So we've been talking about the
authoritarian slide of the United States
over the last many years, which goes beyond
Donald Trump, it accelerated under Donald Trump,
but it actually goes beyond Donald Trump. And
now, for the first time ever, the United States
has actually been listed as a backsliding
democracy. This has never happened before.
The Guardian has a very interesting article about
it. U.S. added to list of backsliding democracies
for the first time. Visible deterioration in
U.S. civil liberties began in at least 2019,
says international think tank. This is the
international idea think tank. Globally,
more than one in four people
live in a backsliding democracy,
a proportion that rises to more than two and three
when you include authoritarian or hybrid regimes,
according to the Stockholm based International
Institute for Democracy and Electoral
Assistance. This year, we coded the United States
as backsliding for the first time. But our data
suggests the backsliding episode began at least
in 2019. The United States is a high performing
democracy and even improved its performance
in indicators of impartial administration,
corruption and predictable enforcement
in 2020. However, the declines in civil
liberties and checks on government indicate that
there are serious problems with the fundamentals
of democracy. A historic turning point came in
2021, when former President Trump questioned the
legitimacy of the 2020 election results. Hudson
pointed to a decline in the quality of freedom
of association and assembly during the summer
of protests in 2020, after the police killing
of George Floyd International Idea based its
assessments on 50 years of democratic indicators
in 160 countries. There are three categories for
democracies, including those that are backsliding
hybrid governments and authoritarian regimes.
Another word for a backsliding democracy
is creeping authoritarianism or autocrats zation
democratic decay. Indeed, democratization a
gradual decline in the quality of democracy
the opposite of democratization. If unchecked
democratic backsliding results in the state,
losing its democratic qualities, becoming an
autocracy or an authoritarian regime, now there's
another aspect to this. The other aspect to this
is that when you talk about authoritarianism
and you talk about people like Donald Trump,
it is not just about what they would like to
see implemented. There's this other aspect we've
talked about which Princeton has studied, which
is whose goals are more likely to be made policy.
And in that sense, the US hasn't really been a
representative democracy for a long time, wherein
the the policy goals of the rich and of big
corporations are far more likely to be made law
than those of the average person. I mean, you
know, you look at things like the estate tax,
the estate tax in which an individual
has an $11 million exemption and a couple
has $22 million in exempt money that
they can pass to heirs tax exempt money
that benefits a very small portion of people. And
yet it has been a mainstay in some form or another
to some degree or another for a long time. And we
talk about so many other rules that benefit large
corporations that that's been a concern for a long
time. And then now, in addition, you have this now
one one last thing I do want to mention about
this. There's another aspect to this, which is
there is the belief from some on the
right that aside from freedom rankings and
all these different things, that there are great
things in the U.S. like, for example, the U.S.
is just the best place to be doing business, to
have a business, to be an entrepreneur. That's
also not true. And it's important when we talk
about pros and cons, every place has pros and
cons. And when we look at something like, Oh
no, now the U.S. is officially a backsliding
democracy when they say, yeah, but it's like the
best place to do business, that's also not true.
And as one example, if you look at the open
for business rankings and you actually look at
what what are the places you see that it's
Switzerland number one, Panama number two,
Canada number three, Canada, Denmark number four,
Sweden places that the right often likes to say
are nanny state. Pseudo socialist places rank
higher for business environment than the United
States New Zealand. Norway, Ireland,
many originally U.S. based businesses,
moving operations are partially moving
operations to Ireland. You have Finland,
Netherlands, Malaysia, Australia, Belgium say it's
a very, very long list before you ultimately get
to the United States, which I can't even find at
this point because it is quite far down the list.
Latvia, Croatia and of course, this has to do with
everything from regulation to amount of paperwork
and the United States ranking 45th in the open for
business rankings, exactly the same as 2020. So
the important thing here is when they say, Well,
you might point out this part, that's not so good,
but this other one is really good. Actually go and
look it up because it's not always the case. And
of course, if you believe in openness, democracy,
anti authoritarianism as I do, you don't want to
see the U.S. listed as a backsliding democracy
for the first time. But alas, that's where we are
and this goes beyond just who's president. This
has this has a lot to do with many different
aspects, including surveillance, including
corruption, including so many different things
not going in the right direction. Let's take a
quick break, and we'll be right back after this.